chômage des jeunes le nombre des
demandeurs d'emploi a baissé de 6,8 pour
ça en dit monsieur black un médecin
accusent leurs bottes frida la
religieuse belge n'a pas tué 3 mai 30
personnes âgées françois mitterrand
avant toute discussion avec les
communistes ils doivent changer la
disposition à notre égard météo
après le froid et la neige voici le
redoux et la pluie et déjà les
inondations
là messieurs bonsoir l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui nous reporte d'abord neuf
mois en arrière ce jour là le 4 avril
dernier
la france découvre l étonnante
confession du jeune femme de 21 ans
sylvie jeu fin voici les clés de mon
appartement allez-y j'y ai laissé mourir
mes enfants en soient d'avis avec quatre
ans sébastien 2 devant une pareille
révélation en a d'abord un haut-le-coeur
et puis on essaie de comprendre ce qui a
bien pu se passer dans la tête de cette
mer c'est ce qu'ont essayé de faire
depuis hier les jurés de rouen qui juge
la jeune femme est à l'instant l'avocat
général vient de requérir 15 ans de
prison
c'est dans cet immeuble que tout s'est
passé deux enfants françois-xavier
quatre ans le plus grand et sébastien
deux ans le 19 mars 77 leur mère sylvie
dauphin a fermé la porte de la chambre
et s'en est allé les enfants sont morts
de faim de soif et peut être aussi de
froid
on a découvert les petits cadavres
quinze jours plus tard c'est leur propre
grand-mère qui finalement a ouvert la
porte de ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
chambre de la mort lente
ce jour là sylvie jovin est apparu comme
un monstre c'est à dire une femme une
mère qui sacrifie ses deux enfants
apparemment de sang mais pour le fait
trop souvent dans ce genre de cas la
société a bon dos et il faut dire que le
contexte qui entoure est où ce procès
toutes ces circonstances est bien avait
une très grosse importance ou est un
procès douloureux difficile que conduire
remarquablement d'ailleurs à rouen le
prof de présidence fans les jurés
devront avoir tout à l'heure à répondre
aux 2 questions ou 2 pourquoi qui se
pose depuis la découverte des enfants
morts pourquoi sylvie jovin qui jusque
là s'étaient battus pour garder surtout
pour nourrir les enfants
pourquoi les at elle abandonné assez
bien le dossier l' enquête répond ceci
civile ofac immature vulnérables timide
issu d'une famille très pauvre de neuf
enfants dont les parents ont très vite
divorcé et est à la recherche de d'un
pivot d'un point solide d'une affection
d'un mari comme les autres en ont elle a
16 ans lorsqu'elle tombe c'est le mou
elle tombe sur un garçon fabrice
letellier qui en fait tout de suite sa
maîtresse premier enfant 17 ans deuxième
enfant 19 ans la vie n'est pas très rose
il ne lui donne que 900 francs par mois
pour tout payer le reste de l'argent
celui qu'ils dépensent pour ses menus
plaisirs mais elle supporte parce qu'il
est là parce qu'elle est sûr qu'un jour
et sur le croit il va l'épouser
mais à noël 76 dire quatre mois à moins
de quatre mois en effet fabrice telliez
la chasse cela renvoie la brandon et
abandonne aussi les deux enfants sans se
préoccuper de savoir qui va lui ouvrir
maintenant alors tout s'écroule pour
sylvie dauphin qui est incapable de
remonter la pente
d'autant que sa famille que sa belle
famille il abandonne aussi que la police
père oublie sa demande de pension
alimentaire que l'assistante sociale de
dieppe ne voit rien que la sécurité
sociale supprime les prestations et que
tous les services sociaux des dalles
enfants sont bizarrement supérieur c'est
le deuxième pourquoi le fonctionnement
de certains services sociaux les
psychiatres et psychologues sont
d'accord là dessus
sylvie jo fin à craquer l'instinct
maternel n'est pas toujours très solide
chez les très jeunes mères elle avait 21
ans je vous le rappelle que s'est il
passé dans sa tête elle et elle est
partie pour se dégager de seconde de
fatalité peut-être avec l'espoir
conscient que quelque chose enfin allait
se produire la sauver et sauver ses
enfants elle était incapable de
s'assumer elle-même rien ne s'est
produit
ce n'est pas très facile d'être juré à
rouen aujourd'hui oui ça c'est pour les
circonstances atténuantes elle a tout de
même laissé mourir de faim deux enfants
donc verdict tard dans la soirée
croyez pas que nous cédions au
sensationnel mais le deuxième titre du
journal de ce soir est tout aussi
incroyable j'avais d'ailleurs commencé à
vous raconter l'histoire la semaine
dernière celle d'une religieuse belge
infirmière d'un hôpital très de gand qui
avait trois morts sur la conscience
trois malades dont elle voulait dit elle
abréger les souffrances et je vous
laissait entendre qu'il y avait
peut-être d'autres cadavres mais nous
n'aurions jamais pu croire que c'est
d'une trentaine de meurtres que nous
allions reparler aujourd'hui c'est
pourtant la révélation que vient de
faire l'un des médecins de cet hospice
de vieillards
le docteur de kort choqué par l'attitude
du conseil d'administration qui voulait
dit-il étouffer la faire je crois qu'il
n'a pas qu'il a eu peur d'un jeu qu'en
danse d'abord et puis qu'il ne sait pas
qui n'a pas compris ce que ça va
signifier
et quand on a commencé dans une
direction est bien difficile de
changé d'avis et je crois que celle là
sa grande foule est ce qu il est exact
que disons la direction d'établissements
étaient au courant déjà en tous les cas
on l'avait averti les infirmières
l'avait averti du danger que
représentait cette soeur c'est à dire le
secrétaire était prévenue parler
ces infirmières qui avait pas mal de
drogue qu'ils étaient prescrits
enfin d'une manière fausse qui avait de
l'insuline prescrits pour des patientes
qui n'était pas diabétique du tout et
les infirmières avaient
visitez le président pour pour lui
raconter le tout le 8 août et le 12 août
selon vous si on était intervenu disons
à l'époque pour empêcher cette
religieuse de travailler on aurait
peut-être pu sauver la vie à deux
personnes
c'est bien possible si on a pris sa
responsabilité tout de suite comment une
personne prête été tués - pour en
terminer avec cette actualité judiciaire
j'ajoute qu'à beauvais l'auteur du viol
de cinq auto stoppeuse a été condamné à
20 ans de prison
c'est la plus forte peine jamais
prononcée dans un procès de ce genre
la campagne électorale ce n'est pas
seulement cette succession de petites
phrases dans nos journaux sont
malheureusement trop remplie c'est aussi
parfois l'occasion de débattre de
dossiers bien concret en voici deux ce
soir au coeur de la bataille premier
sujet l'emploi ou chômage comme on
voudra un moment où la polémique reprend
autour des chiffres donnés la semaine
dernière par christian bilhac le cnpf
monte en première ligne en affirmant que
90% des 500 mille emplois proposés aux
jeunes seront définitifs et le président
république en conseil des ministres ce
matin souligne lui même l'effort
accompli par le gouvernement et les
entreprises
ce demi million de postes de travail
recouvre différentes situations
le 125 mille jeunes ont été engagés
définitivement selon les voies
habituelles du recrutement 108000 sont
en apprentissage et le cnpf estime que
plus de 90% d'entre eux conserveront
leur travail une fois leur apprentissage
terminé 23 mille jeunes bénéficient du
contrat emploi formation et 145 mille
sont en stage pratique
les trois quarts d'entre eux toujours
selon le cnpf verront leur stage
transformer un emploi définitif à la fin
de leur contrat
ces chiffres sont rendus publics alors
que rebondi l'accord elle des
statistiques sur le chômage
l'insee estime aujourd'hui à 1 millions
63 mille le nombre des demandeurs
d'emploi à fin janvier alors que le
ministère du travail avait donné la
semaine dernière le chiffre d'un million
une querelle évoqué ce matin par le
premier ministre à sa sortie de l'elysée
les ministres ont bien fait leur travail
on les oublie toujours ils sont l'objet
de sarcasmes de critiques de
l'accusation de manipulation est bien là
il y à un fait et je peux porter
témoignage du travail que le ministres
et deux secrétaires d'état ont accompli
depuis le mois d'avril pour mettre sur
pied le programme pour le faire voter et
pour l'appliquer je voudrais en second
lieu signaler que ce texte ces textes de
lois qui ont permis le pacte national
pour l'emploi n'ont pas été votées pour
par l'opposition alors que l'emploi des
jeunes est une affaire nationale
ministre en question avait l'air bien
content deuxième dossier social de la
campagne smic
vous savez que le premier le parti
communiste a proposé à 2400 francs dès
avril et qu'il y a peu de temps le ps
s'est aligné sur cette position jusqu
alors dans la majorité ont jugé
l'initiative démagogique mais voilà que
samedi dernier sur cette chaîne
jean-jacques servan-schreiber dès qu'il
faut aller faut dire oui au smic à 2400
francs car le nom serait
incompréhensible
oui à condition de ne pas faire tout
tout de suite
et hier soir sur tf1 raymond barre suit
en partie cette même voie mais se refuse
à donner une date précise en tout cas
pas dans l'année à venir
je crois qu'il ya eu effectivement un
phénomène de réaction en chaîne ou si
vous préférez un phénomène
d'entraînement il faut bien préciser je
crois d'abord que si le parti socialiste
s'est aligné sur l'attitude du parti
communiste après l'avoir rejeté au
départ ce n'était pas pour faire plaisir
au parti communiste pour gommer une
divergence pour rendre plus facile la
reprise des négociations de façon si
négociations ne sont pas encore prises
pour faire 10 et à l'électorat
oui je crois que c'est essentiellement
parce que le parti socialiste a senti
l'impact de la proposition communiste
sur l'opinion publique en particulier
sur l'électorat ouvrier et puis s'il en
observant shreiber il ya quelques jours
antenne 2
hier affirmé que dire non à
l'augmentation du smic à 2400 francs
serait une attitude irresponsable c'est
parce que lui aussi a senti l'impact de
cette proposition qui était devenue la
proposition de toute la gauche il
estimait que l'ensemble de la majorité
ne pouvais pas dire non à cette
proposition
alors je crois que cette évolution
autour du smic montre deux choses la
première on ironise beaucoup en période
électorale sur les batailles de chiffres
auxquels tout le monde finit par le plus
bien comprendre grand chose
eh bien il ya quand même quelques
chiffres bien précis bien limitée qui
prennent tout leur sens
et il y a aussi des problèmes bien
concret qui sont très mobilisateur et
puis deuxième remarque il ya toujours en
période électorale une bataille entre
ceux qui promettent ce qui leur paraît
souhaitable et ceux qui répondent et
bien oui c'est souhaitable mais ça n'est
pas possible
il arrive un moment où le souhait est si
fort c'était le cas par exemple pour les
congés payés ou bien pour l'âge de la
retraite il arrive un moment où le
souhait est si fort que tout le monde
cherche à rendre possible ce qui est
souhaitable je crois d'ailleurs que
c'est une des nombreuses définitions de
la politique de la politique qui en
cette affaire a pris le pas sur
l'économie en affaires c'est quand même
aussi une barrette de shit mills acier
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous ai
demandé de venir pour essayer de
décortiquer un petit peu cette bataille
de chiffres le smic à 2015 ce n'est pas
toujours facile et décortiqué méfaits et
contre le possible souhaitable et bien
cela donne une belle bataille de
chiffres en fait le problème sur le fond
qui est posée est le suivant quand et
comment est ce que l'on peut faire
accepter par l'économie française une
hausse de plus de 30% du smic vrai
comparable à celle de 1968 lesquels sera
la répercussion de cette hausse sur les
autres salaires vous savez que le parti
socialiste propose que tous les salaires
augmentent jusqu'à ce qu'ils
représenteront 4 fois le smic leur smic
à eux de mika souffrance c'est à dire
jusqu'au salaire de 9600 francs mais
attention du style daisy socialiste plus
les salaires seront au et plus les eaux
seront faibles alors voici un petit peu
de s'y retrouver ce qu'il vient dans
tous ces chiffres on la prend d'abord le
secteur privé les industries les
services et le commerce qui est le
premier intéressé il y à 13 millions de
salariés dans ce secteur de l'industrie
du commerce privé un salarié sur trois
gad moins de 2400 font donc il est
directement intéressé par les
propositions du parti socialiste pour
ceux qui sont au bas de l'échelle pour
les véritables smic à l'augmentation de
la feuille de paie sera de 30
7 5% c'est-à-dire on passera de 1750 à
2400 francs par mois ensuite les hausses
vont s'échelonner za c'est la question
que se pose évidemment les gens qui ont
un petit peu plus de 1400 comprend alors
voilà combien est bien là françois
garand dans l'accueil que vous citiez
tout à l'heure au monde cet après midi a
dit qu'il y aura des discussions entre
les différents partenaires sociaux mais
encore une fois combien cela va-t-il
coûter
et bien selon des experts qui
n'appartiennent pas à des partis
politiques en 1968 et pour le secteur
privé
78 78 pardon et pour le secteur privé
la majoration pour les entreprises
privées de cette augmentation du smic et
les répercussions tel complot
actuellement les définir sera de 40
milliards c'est un chiffre un peu
approximatif parce que je n'y ajoute pas
les charges sociales qui forcément
montereau et je ne retrouve pas les
propositions des socialistes qui sont de
d'aider les entreprises dans leur
donnant deux cents francs par an prison
40 milliards c'est donc le coup en 1978
de cette mesure maintenant qu'est-ce que
je représente l'économie française en
année pleine ces terres du 1er janvier
au 31 décembre
il y a dix sept millions de salariés et
là je compte on seulement l'industrie
mais les fonctionnaires et l'agriculture
la masse de ces salaires a représenté en
1976 600 milliards c'est un chiffre
arrondi et là le programme socialiste et
bien se traduirait par une augmentation
toujours moyenne de son dif bien alors
il était intéressant de savoir ce qu'en
pense le principal intéressé le cnpf
écoutez la réponse parfaite à jacques
merino yvon chotard le vice président du
patronat
en ce qui concerne le strict
notre avis est très clair le spica 2400
francs au 1er avril c'est la faillite de
la salanque d'entreprise et c'est
l'augmentation du chômage
mais l'objectif d'augmenter le smic est
aussi notre objectif
le problème est de savoir à quel moment
on peut atteindre les 2400 francs or
qu'est ce qui vient de se passer dans
les dix années écoulées les dix années
écoulées
le smic a augmenté de 350 % en valeur
réelle il a doublé en dix ans il faut
que la situation économique soit tels
que l'on puisse avancer plus vite et
nous en ce qui nous concerne nous
souhaitons que la situation économique
permettent d'aller plus vite
4 dossier ce matin en conseil des
ministres la préparation du budget 79 la
création du commissariat à l'énergie
solaire annoncées par le chef de l'état
au début du mois nous l'avions alors
comment t'es tu lui berio une série de
mesures pour la sécurité du travail
il faut savoir que le nombre des
accidents a baissé de trois et demi pour
176 et le gouvernement a adopté six
mesures pour tout cela continue encore
nous vous avons donné hier soir et puis
dernier dossier
l'accroissement de l'aide aux industries
agroalimentaires qui en ont bien besoin
un mot sur la santé des monnaies comme
chaque soir est bien le franc n'a pas
bougé aujourd'hui le dollar continue de
s'effriter et franc suisse atteint des
sommets il est aujourd'hui coté à 2
francs 78 32e congrès de la fnsea
aujourd'hui et demain à versailles
réunion rituel chaque année mais qui en
78 à 18 jours de l'élection ne pouvait
pas ne pas avoir une tonalité
particulière
ils étaient plus de 800 ce matin à
assister au 32e congrès de la fnsea
versailles
la fnsea qui revendique 750 mille
adhérents
depuis quelques mois les agriculteurs
ont à nouveau l'impression d'être des
mal aimés
on leur reproche trop à leur goût d'être
responsable des hausses des prix des
produits alimentaires
mais le fait de le plus remarquable ce
sont les quelques grognements de la base
conséquence de l'un d'entre eux la
fédération de la loire atlantique a été
exclu des instances nationales
mais pour michel de battice le principal
problème reste le revenu des
agriculteurs
les agriculteurs pendant quatre années
consécutives ont vu leurs revenus
pratiquement diminué seul en 1977 il y à
une légère augmentation est notre
préoccupation principale
au cours de ce congrès est de mettre en
place les moyens d'obtenir pour 1978 une
amélioration du revenu des agriculteurs
certains sont tentés de vous reprocher
justement au moment où comment ce
congrès de vous reprocher votre
engagement politique avoue michel
débâtisse je ne suis ni candidat aux
élections législatives
je ne suis membre d'aucun parti
politique
je suis simplement le président de la
fédération des exploitants qui a un
mandat
ce mandat expire aujourd'hui et ce sont
les agriculteurs qui vont être juge et
qui vont décider s'ils me font à nouveau
confiance ces 32e congrès de la fnsea
devrait faire date dans les annales de
l'organisation et ceci à plusieurs
titres
tout d'abord il se situe à 18 jours des
élections législatives
certains y voilà déjà une option
politique ensuite pour la première fois
depuis 32 ans
la fnsea invitait un leader d'une
centrale syndicale ouvrière à s'exprimer
ce sera demain matin andré bergeron pour
fo enfin et surtout je dirais des
congressistes vont se pencher pendant
deux jours sur un thème de réflexion
intitulée la démocratie économique
il sera certainement question du danger
de l'engagement politique pour un
syndicat et on aboutira surtout sur un
certain choix de société dans ces
conditions on ne peut douter de
l'importance politique de ce congrès où
malgré tout les hommes en place michel
de bâtisses en tête devraient être
reconduits dans leurs fonctions
réponse ce soir après les élections
internes à la fédération
marcel jullian chevalier de la légion
d'honneur notre ancien pdg en a reçu les
insignes du mende et des mains du chef
de l'état il ya quelques mini chef de
l'état qui dans l'après midi où
l'entendait s'était rendu à allainville
les roches dans la région parisienne
devant l'école nationale des sapeurs
pompiers
l'occasion de rendre hommage à ces deux
cent vingt mille sapeurs les neuf
dixièmes sur des volontaires qui
interviennent dans la calculer en
moyenne qui plaît 25 ans
sur un peu voilà six ans la route en
tout ce sont plus de 600 mille personnes
qui ont été secourues et asnières
l'occasion aussi pour le président la
république d'élargir son discours à la
sécurité des français aspirent
aujourd'hui plus que jamais à la
sécurité la sécurité dans leur vie de
tous les jours leur sécurité personnelle
la sécurité de leurs biens la sécurité
dans leur habitat la sécurité dans leur
travail
un renforcement des moyens de sécurité
sera mise en place dès cette année 1978
et le gouvernement arrêtera les
dispositions nécessaires dans un
prochain conseil des ministres notamment
ce renforcement sera prévue dans les
grandes zones d'urbanisation où
l'insécurité est la plus vivement
ressentie par la population comme
également dans certaines banlieues des
grandes villes
il compte en effet désormais assurée
dans tous les quartiers d'habitation une
présence suffisante des personnels
chargés de la sécurité publique
qu'il s'agisse de la police ou de la
gendarmerie
la sécurité c'est aussi la lutte contre
les accidents
alors que la maladie a reculé devant les
réussites de la médecine alors que notre
pays vit en paix depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années
et pour la première fois de son histoire
les accidents font encore chaque année
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
victimes
la sécurité c'est enfin la sphère de
tous les français
chacun petit contribuer grâce à une
meilleure information sur les risques
grâce à une meilleure conscience de ses
responsabilités moins d'insouciance ou
d'imprudence pourrait en effet sauvé des
milliers de vies c'est pourquoi la
politique nationale de sécurité civile
sera poursuivie avec détermination dans
trois directions
une prévention accrue des moyens
d'intervention renforcer une formation
des hommes accélérée et améliorée mais
les risques dans l'east 1 s'est aussi
engagé à mener une action résolue contre
l'alcoolisme source de nombreux
accidents en quelques minutes c'est à
dire à la fin de ce journal ou pour
assister à notre dernier cartes sur
table avant les élections michel vigneau
ce qui sera le dernier des grands
leaders interrogé par jean-pierre
elkabbach et allah dieu mais qu'ils sont
déjà là comme on sait que l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur dit souvent tout
ce que le chef de l'état pense tout bas
mais je crois que c'est un rendez vous à
ne pas rater
la campagne est orale c'est aussi une
série de petit speech qui vont parfois
c'est loin jacques chirac à montpellier
estime que monsieur mitterrand et de
ceux qui ont mené la france à deux
doigts de la guerre civile
olivier stirn reprochent au socialiste
jean pierre chevènement d'être un
communiste honte je vous préfère marcher
dit il qui ont au moins la franchise de
ses opinions
françois mitterrand lui n'a pas le même
langage mais répond trêve ironiquement
lorsque tout à l'heure pendant le
déjeuner de l'après secret diplomatique
pardon on lui demande s'il veut bien
frotter raymond barre à la télévision il
faut pour l'instant ce débat nous paraît
pas du tout à la veille d'être organisée
nancy les chaînes de télévision sans se
mêler de tout ces détails parviennent à
établir entre les uns les autres
ce n'est pas du tout à une possible
hausse par un refus de principe
ça sera bien un jour ça me parait
mettant bien tard par rapport au 12 mars
d'autant plus que dans la campagne
électorale se permettait ce sera ma
réponse principale je trouve que
monsieur bart finalement ne présentent
pas beaucoup voire présente pas beaucoup
la présente ni l'udf ni le rpr et ce qui
représente les centristes lorsque la
syrah et représente pas non plus en
dépit des dernières déclarations de
socialisme et s'il s'agit de quelqu'un
capable de représenter le tout sauf le
dernier point je veux dire le socialiste
giscard d'estaing suffit à la peine donc
monsieur bart c'est un peu quelqu'un
comment dirais-je
c'est quelqu'un qui se trouve en double
en bis alors je vois pas très bien la
nécessité pour le premier responsable du
parti socialiste de parler avec personne
et je te que françois mitterrand avait
dit ce passage là ne passera pas la
télévision
il est passé beaucoup plus sérieusement
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste a répondu à georges marchais
qui avaient fait hier soir à reims un
petit pas dans sa direction en lui
proposant de reprendre sans délai sans
préalable la discussion réponse de
françois mitterrand at-elle entretien
devrait être précédée par les
dispositions nouvelles du pc à notre
égard
pour l'heure donc le ps maintient son
refus de négocier la colonisation avant
le 19 mars mais il ya peut-être quelques
petits signes de dégel entre les deux
partenaires de la gauche françois
mitterrand dans une galerie au monde
avait par ailleurs répété que la gauche
aurait la même politique que le ps dise
tout dans la politique plus ars et cette
petite brochure du cds que j'ai reçu
c'est le programme des centristes en
bande dessinée
tout le monde fait les efforts pour être
plus clair c'est aussi le cas d'un
nouveau confrère qui s'appelle tout
simplement et qui veut tous les
trimestres à duire en termes clairs et
simples les textes importants de la vie
politique et pratique des france
dernières techniques pour mieux
appréhender la politique ce que nous
faisons depuis le début de la semaine
avec lous dous et à chinon aujourd'hui
dernier volet de notre enquête qui n'est
pas vraiment une enquête mais plutôt une
somme d'impression
comment les français à chinon en tout
cas jugent leurs hommes politiques
au début de ce reportage quelqu'un nous
disait tout le monde veut le bonheur des
gens il n'ya que les conceptions
philosophiques ti chance or dans
l'esprit de bien des gens précisément la
politique c'est quoi et bien souvent
comme il ne la voit qu'à travers l'homme
qui regardent à la télé l'homme qu'ils
écoutent celui dont ils lisent les
déclarations dans les journaux sur les
affiches
la politique c'est d'abord celui ci l'a
fait le politicien et ses petits lequel
ne squatte que cela a commencé par les
jeunes à l'heure du choix
enfin parce sont pas au même niveau que
disons
que ce qu'on entend des deux
habituellement par politique la
politique
on la voit le voile à bord à paris
comment les gens de divers partis se bat
que pour arriver à quelque chose et nous
on le ressent avant en moins ça comme ça
mais je crois qu'on devrait pas
ressentir cette façon ça ne vous laisse
pas indifférent face au clan ça ne
laisse pas indifférent le percement je
trouve ça un peu un peu dommage que dès
que les gens s'entretuent femmes 138
femmes qui se casse un peu du sucre
comme ça vous pour pas grand chose
bon ou un changement qui n'est pas
cessera paraître cage au magazine
politique on est enfin ont tous des
travers que qui finalement qui sont à
base de toute discussion maintenant
quand d'à-propos toute polémique on est
d'abord en en avant les défauts des
défauts les hommes politiques ou
délictuelles
ban est de poser vraiment un problème
comment photographier quand un homme
politique
quelle image on garde haute au delà de
l'espèce de litchi sociale qui inscrit
la vie locale dans un code auquel chacun
souscrite en gros tout le monde n'est
pas forcément beau tout même et pas
forcément gentil mais que l'on soit d'un
bord ou de l'autre c'est à dire d'accord
ou pas avec un tel cirque ça au delà de
la critique
que reste-t-il de l'homme politique est
là où ils sont ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent souvent quand
j'entends critiquer tel ou tel homme
politique ou tel ou tel notable dans une
villa le telle ou telle mère tel ou tel
conseiller municipal tel ou tel
conseiller général j'ai envie de dire
aux gens mais bon dieu mettez vous à
leur place
est ce que vous croyez vous auriez des
mains mieux est ce que vous croyez que
par la vertu de de quelques dont un
mystérieux ne pas vous auriez été plus
plus adroits plus habiles plus et plus
efficace souventes fois ici ce qui se
passe dans nos milieux
on regarde beaucoup l'homme beaucoup
l'homme la qualité de l'homme quelle
qu'elle soit et c'est l'option volée que
oui et ça se traduit par quoi alors et
bien que l'homme a donné les services en
ligne envoyer un homme politique ça
c'est donc un homme qui vous rendrez des
services une sorte d'assistance sociale
et oui et non si vous voulez la
politique quel que soit son parti il est
dans une séquence et sur les délits bon
sur l'homme opposition majorité ou des
restaurants il doit être au service où
l'aide de tout le monde et si cet
homme-là sait se faire apprécier mais
l'utilisera dialyse
les gens sont honnêtes quelle conviction
ont-ils je pense que ici vous savez
comme dans beaucoup de pays en france on
vit une période de bouleversements qui
préoccupe et qui pose beaucoup
d'interrogations la télévision informe
comme vous dites
à la limite je me demande si elle ne
pose pas beaucoup de questions laissées
sans réponse
ou alors disons que les réponses un peu
brutale qu'on donne ne satisfont pas moi
je reste persuadé que les temps
difficiles que nous vivons dans ces
communes rurales voyez ici de 300
habitants 400 habitants ces temps
difficiles que nous vivons laisse les
gens vraiment préoccupé et incertain
quant à leur avenir
quel avenir de d'une france rurale qui
reste essentiel pour l'équilibré du pays
tout entier
voilà faudrait que l'on ajouté un veau
enfin une phrase c'est les deux rabelais
rabelais qui passa toute son enfance
dans cette maison qui on appelle la
devinière ou et froid ou ait raison ou l
humanité ou et crainte de dieu défendre
ma maison et nos amis se courir contre
les assauts des malfaisants
fin de citation ça te regarde sur la
politique les relations entre le caire
et nicosie sont ce soir totalement rompu
l'egypte ne reconnaît plus monsieur qui
est à nous comme président de la
république chypriote a déclaré le
président sadate à l'occasion des
obsèques des 15 membres du commando tué
sur l'aéroport de larnaca un président
sadate très ému au milieu d'une foule
énorme vous le voyez des dizaines de
milliers d'égyptiens étaient là dans une
excitation assez folle une bousculade
alors que retentissaient les marches de
les accents de la marche funèbre de rhj
après marek halter et de nombreuses
personnalités de gauche et cette fois
l'écrivain jean françois revel qui
propose le boycott de la coupe du monde
de football en argentine cet été mais il
demande également le boycott des jeux
olympiques de moscou dans deux ans le
point sur le temps à présent après le
froid très vif du week-end leur douche
et les inondations risquent pour
l'instant l'ile-de-france et la
seine-et-marne sont surtout toucher et à
paris la seine devrait à nouveau débordé
sur les voies sur berge la côte d'
alerte dépasser de plus d'un mètre en
seine-et-marne pour la dans la seule
journée d'aujourd'hui il y en ait monté
de 20 cm et plusieurs routes sont
coupées dans la manche la situation
n'est pas meilleure
300 commerçants du centre de granville
inondé déjà plus de 10 millions de
francs de dégâts
la loire n'épargne pas non plus le
nivernais où de nombreuses progressons
submerge et tout ne fait que commencer
si on en croit les services de la
météorologie qui prévoit d'autres
inondations importantes surtout dans le
nord-est et le sud ouest ou avec le
redoux la fonte des neiges a commencé et
oui les crues risque de s'aggraver en
fin de semaine avec les pluies que
prévoit la météo comme déjà dufour
demain les températures seront encore en
hausse avec des pluies passagères
surtout ouest de la france
j'en profite pour vous dire dès
maintenant que si vous habitez la région
parisienne et que vous voulez profiter
des vacances scolaires de vos enfants
qui commence samedi
évitez je vous en prie de prendre la
route samedi entre 4 heures du matin et
16 voilà vous avez un année rendez-vous
avec l'actualité à 22h30 en compagnie de
gérard holtz sur a le plaisir de vous
retrouver quant à moi de demain bonne
soirée à tous cartes sur table suis dans
quelques minutes
à